Jetts blow a 16-point lead at home to
lose week one and then before the Monday
nighter Sam darn old comes down with
mononucleosis the worst Madlib in New
York Jets history or at least the one
since Ryan Fitzpatrick gets the start
because Geno Smith had his jaw
rearranged by his teammate think you got
it all did I get it all I think so
well I don't know if I got it all
another expert on this subject is
joining us back on the rich highs and
show my greenberg did I get it right
green in order to get it all we would
need about three or four days to have
this conversation but I think you have
touched on the most important and
salient point I'm trying to come up with
a joke that says something along the
lines up what do my 15 year old niece
and the starting quarterback of the New
York Jets have in common
oh my gosh they're both gonna miss a
little time with mono it's it you could
not make this up if you tried you know
you couldn't I mean so and I say here
then what I tweeted out earlier I know
you're a busy man I don't know if you
saw it but you said that you're renaming
your children Sam and Arnold you can
rename them mono and nucleosis how does
nucleosis greenberg hit you actually
taking her off to college this weekend
we're taking a little nucleosis to
Northwestern on Saturday listen this is
so depressing that my mind actually went
to the worst possible place now I'll
give you the worst case okay and and
then we'll work our way back to the best
case I want to ask you an honest
question as a fan of the jet yes sir
because because you and I when we were
together we talked about how tough the
start of the schedule is no no it just
could have been a reasonably good team
and been one in six losing beat winning
the buffalo games felt absolutely
paramount so the Jets could play even
better than we expect them to and still
be hopelessly buried by the time same
Journal comes back if they are if the
Jets are staring at Owen soil which
feels like a very real possibility right
now would you Rich Eisen trade glossy on
bail ah would I trade levy on bail look
at you brown everything goes by with him
is one
further from his maximum from his prime
they'd be traded him in October of this
year you would probably get a pretty
significant return this year is a wash
you're probably better off and I hate
even saying this out loud but once
you're owing for winning games actually
become somewhat contrary to your bigger
picture objectives I'm not suggesting
tanking or anything like that but I am
suggesting that having levy on bail on
an Owen 14 is you know insert your joke
here having really fancy rims on a car
that has no engine so would you if there
was some team out there that felt they
were a running back away they felt they
were levy on bail away from winning the
Superbowl and offered you a really big
haul of draft fix if you were the Jets
would you do that deal I would not Mike
I would not be on bail is at the
beginning of his peak years even Owen
four is not the end of it I mean I I
could I could go you know Joe Walton on
you here I mean they could pull a
reverse Joe Walton and go in a different
direction I cuz again you know I it
depends on on who would be who would be
so desperate as to trade for levy on
bail in the middle of the season I don't
I don't know who would do something like
that it's a great fodder for for a
conversation like we're having but still
Sam Donald's 22 levy on bail is what
brought Ben 26 I mean it's it makes I
wouldn't do it Mike you would would you
really know I don't know that I would or
not but the thought crossed my mind in
the mere fact that the thought of
whether or not they should trade Le'Veon
Bell one game into his tenure because
you would get is about the most
depressing thing I can imagine now
because I'll be spitting it back to the
good news yes so Trevor Simeon is
someone I know well Trevor Simeon was
the quarterback at Northwestern which is
where I went to school yes sir and I
have been telling everyone who would
listen Trevor siemian is going to make a
living in the National Football League
for 15 years because he is exactly what
you want to backup quarterback to be he
is a guy who can keep the ship afloat
for a couple of weeks I've always said
if your quarterback badly sprained his
ankle I didn't anticipate mononucleosis
but they are for the purposes of this
discussion the same thing I think the
Jets I
trevor simian is more than good enough
to win a game or two for the jacks now
what you just ran through the schedule
week three is New England they weren't
going to win that game anyway it would
be awfully surprising if they won that
game regardless of who the quarterback
was this is why losing the Buffalo was
so ridiculously damaging because now
they have to be cleveland if you don't
think leave you know you know the
numbers better than I do you start a
season out going three your chances of
making the playoffs are so infinitesimal
that it feels hopeless so Monday night
feels like it is the season and the good
news for anyone else listening I was a
fan of the Jets is that I have faith in
Trevor said neither good player he's not
meant to be someone starter for a decade
but he is a good backup and he is more
than capable of coming in and playing
well enough if the defense is really
good on Monday night for the Jets to
have a real chance to work well here's
the deal mike Greenberg ESPN my compadre
in this world of misery for the Jets
right here on the Rich Eisen show here's
the deal Mike is that yes they should
win a game in New England week three
that's the defeatist the defeatist
attitude that so many jet fans and I
understand why it's had but yes they
should win week three because Sam Donald
is supposed to be the guy in year two to
walk in with levy on bail behind him and
Adam GaSe coordinating it even we might
be the guy might not be the guy but it's
time it's time how many franchises can
discover their newfound savior in the
draft
the Browns clearly have somebody that
they can hang their hat on the Chiefs
had the dream come true Tom Brady thing
bestowed upon them we could keep going
on and on about this and it doesn't
happen to the Jets and darn 'old I'm
afraid right now greeny still his
high-water mark is coming back on the
Lions in his first game in which he
threw a pick six to start his career
when is it going this is this is the
issue that this should be it now I mean
they should go into a place like New
England they should be able to look the
Eagles in the face in their house and
say Sam Donald's for real these are
Wentz right but he's our Goff
that's that's the thing that should be
happening right now and it's not and it
might not even this year we might have
to wait till next year Mike right if we
lived in an alternative universe then
all those things might be what were
happening but what is actually happening
is that there was a moment in time on
Sunday when the jet defense had forced
four turnovers recorded safety and
scored a touchdown and they were in a
one score game with the Buffalo Bills
that happened so the Jets offense on
Sunday was so bad so unimaginative so
ridiculously disappointing that even
before Darnell
came down with mono I was extremely
concerned like III don't know what you
thought I hated what I saw from the
offense on Sunday I thought it was
ridiculously predictable it was
unimaginative
it was obviously offensive line had no
chance of protecting dartle and yet they
kept sending him back into that same
drop with no no no threat of moving him
around in the pocket or anything like
that what she does so well how many
balls can have batted down the line of
scrimmage before you say we need to try
something different and they did then
question what got his annual out for the
season injury I can't believe he got to
do one entire game before he was placed
on injured reserve for the year so all
the things that make people use anyone
around the country who is not familiar
with the Jets may not know these three
words that you and I know far too well
it makes people say same old Jets and
that unfortunately is what it feels like
and I am fighting like crazy the
inclination to just throw my hands up in
the air and say there we go again but it
would be hard for me to deny that there
is a part of me that is thinking that
right now all right so let's use it
before I let you go my Greenberg let's
let's use our smile as our umbrella top
five most shall we say mmm embarrassing
I don't know if embarrassing is the word
most typical Jets moment okay well so
here's here's my list tell me if there's
anything missing on this list not in no
particular order is Belichick leaving
after 24 hours resigning on a cocktail
napkin
but fumble okay the fake spike where
Marino beats the Jets with a fake spike
Geno Smith gets his jaw rearranged
leading to fits magic and fits magic
teases well enough to take us to week 17
for him to only turn over the ball 17
times against the bills again to lose
that and then then there's this right
this is in their Sam Donald gets
mononucleosis to put a comeback season
which there's so much hope in am I
missing anything those would be my worst
moments in church history they may be
the most infamous moments in Jets
history I mean Mark Gastineau once
rushed to the quarterback in Cleveland
in a playoff game on a fourth down where
the game would have been over they
called roughing the quarterback and
instead they tried to end up losing in
double overtime that was a playoff game
that wound up leading look around but
then bro greeny like that sounds like
you know everybody's got their bad beats
in poker you know their bad beats to use
a SVP phrase I'm talking about this is
the fingerprint of the New York Jets
here okay who else has who else has an
all-time modern-day Lombardi say I'm out
after 24 hours you know I didn't even
include Moe Lewis assuring in the Tom
Brady era who else who else has on
national TV on Thanksgiving
their quarterback who so much hope was
put in because of two back-to-back
championship game appearances who has
him disintegrate in front of the nation
by running into the taint of his linemen
who else who else has their so-called
hope at quarterback that they've got one
last shot at because they drafted him in
the second round lose that opportunity
because he has his jaw rearranged by his
teammate I mean maybe another franchise
that's got all that on their resume
before all this Mike I gladly can see
this those feel like the right things to
name and it's not in this circumstance I
mean the Jets up until a few of these
records were broken the Jets had drafted
a quarterback ahead of the all-time
leading passer drafted a running back
ahead of the all-time leading rusher and
drafted a receiver ahead of the all-time
leading
reciever the the quarterback record and
the running back record ever since been
the running back Greg there's still fame
they drafted a running back ahead of
Emmitt Smith a draft to receive her head
of Jerry Rice and they drafted a
quarterback ahead of Dan Marino marinos
records have since been broken but that
that's sort of the lot in life of the
Jets fan and unfortunately here it seems
sort of continuous so I that's not a bad
one right there to put on the top five
but this one's up there I mean this is
nuts man no no I dude yes as your point
Trevor Simeon is a guy who's won
football games before he could be able
to come in here if levy but if loving on
bells out with us that with his shoulder
I don't know that's gonna be a tall
order man the defense was basically a
tale of two games there was before CJ
Moseley got hurt and after CJ Moseley
got hurt I don't know yet it mostly is
gonna play Monday night or not and look
they get a Brownstein that comes in
desperate Hotel Beckham coming back to
New York which is obviously a huge deal
there's one thing we know for sure he'll
know what time it is throughout the
entirety of the game and and it sets up
but in the drama is remarkable both
teams desperately need the wind and now
the Jets unfortunately go into it
without the guy who was in theory their
best boy
well that's by the way that's not a bad
company man but you right there that's
good that's not a bad promo from under
night football still turn in one team
still got a shot despite their
quarterback having mono I can't believe
it Mike hey listen at least you still
have your Mets right well look enjoy I
know that it's bittersweet when when a
kid goes I don't know actually from what
I'm one day I will experience this as
you pointed out when we chatted all fair
the other day are taking taking your kid
to Northwestern that what a beautiful
school as you all know so tell nucleosis
greenberg we we send our best I will
thank you my man good to talk to you
we'll do it next time under more
pleasant circumstances call brother you
got that's my greenberg four more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app